el periodista norteamericano evanskovic
seguirá preso en Rusia el tribunal de
Moscú ha denegado la apelación de su
equipo legal que escovich fue detenido
Hace tres semanas en la ciudad de
ekaterimburgo cerca de los urales las
autoridades rusas le acusan de haber
estado recabando allí información
secretos de estado para pasarselos a una
potencia extranjera a su país a Estados
Unidos tanto el gobierno norteamericano
como el medio para el que trabajaban los
covich el Wall Street journal han negado
estas acusaciones hoy lo hemos visto por
primera vez después de su detención no
ha sido posible hablar con él pero sí
que se le ha visto tranquilo y animado
por otros colegas de los medios de
comunicación ayer la embajadora
norteamericana tuvo ocasión de hablar
con él durante unos instantes en privado
y asegura que se encuentra bien de salud
y de ánimo a pesar de su situación legal
puesto que por los cargos de espiona Je
se expone a una posible pena de hasta 20
años de prisión en